auf der richter wird das werden wir
sehen letztes mal war das witzig
auftritte das video in die seite zu
finden ist das mikrofon an und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir auch übrigens ich weiß man haare
sind kann passiert aus das habe ich auch
schon mal gesagt die wurden auch rasiert
von jemandem der es absolut nicht kann
schöne grüße gehen raus und dann auf
jeden fall gibt es heute einen neuen
part von essens tests aus aller welt
oder so ein guter name dafür
ich habe letztens schon mal ein video
hochgeladen da habe ich so eine erstens
box aus japan vorgestellt
also wir haben hier wirklich glasklare
cola als richtige kohler mit bisschen
bisher so weit so richtig so hier alle
leute einer der spannendsten momente
meines lebens
das sind zu boxen da sind halt spezielle
essens trainer süßigkeiten getränke aus
einem bestimmten fernen land aus dieser
welt drin und das macht eigentlich echt
spaß und hier vor mir liegt jetzt gerade
die nächste box die wir heute auf machen
werden wenn man an dieser stelle danke
ans netbook sie mir geschickt echt
korrekt also habe ich nicht selber
zusammengestellt das ist halt alles von
blackbox von asche die welt danke das
erste video hatten wir unter viel spaß
gemacht einfach diese ganzen neuen
sachen kennenzulernen diese ganzen neuen
geschmäcker
deswegen würde ich sagen wir checken
jetzt zwar diese box after school ist
ich weiß absolut sich um welches land es
sich handeln wird deswegen machen wir
das jetzt mal kurz auf
das könnte interessant werden und zwar
haben wir hier das land kanada kanada
da bin ich mal gespannt richtig gespannt
vor allem hier kann man jetzt auch
wenigstens mal verstehen was draufsteht
dass beides in japan video da könnte man
ja nix verstehen jetzt noch immer dann
so infos zu einem produkten die drin
sind dabei es ist echt nice gemacht und
ich würde sagen ich ziehe es eins nach
dem anderen raus wir beschäftigen uns
kurz damit probieren das und das machen
wir so lange bis die box leer ist also
mexiko produkt nummer eins und zwar
haben wir hier weg coups dessen chips
oder mit barbecue beef geschmack bei
normaler chips jeder kann haben sich die
kanadier gedacht machen wir aus den
kartoffeln doch hula hoops mit barbecue
geschmack also da bin ich mal gespannt
also es riecht auf jeden fall sehr
intensiv nach barbecue bauplatz
schmecken kann
da fragen wir die erinnern mich an
irgendwie so ein chips sorge die wir
hier haben probieren diesen tornados
vielleicht ich weiß nicht was leider ist
ne also schmeckt auf jeden fall gut aber
ist jetzt für mich nichts ausgefallen
ist was sie vorher neu ist deswegen noch
mal schnell weiter brain waste
was ist dass das hier sind chips aus
getreidekörnern und gehören zu einem
tochterunternehmen von pepsi caserta
mich erst mal so ein bisschen an
abschuss ob das was werden kann werden
wir jetzt erfahren
also ich muss sagen ich weiß gar nicht
also wirklich nullkommanull also bis
jetzt immer nicht von der japan boxee
wir das machen falls ihr das video
gesehen habe auf jeden fall hier nach ab
deutlich mehr begeistert aber was nicht
ist kann ja noch werden zum beispiel mit
den marienberg swedish berrys aber ich
glaube wir in kanada zu gut was hat und
das ist mit schwänzen
also das war mal ein schwedisches
unternehmen das hat aber nach kanada
expandiert und ist jetzt dort sehr
erfolgreich und verkauft diese swedish
berrys in form von fischen dokument ja
gut ich singe jetzt nicht aus wie ein
fisch ohne dass bernie das ist ein
richtig guter junge saß intensiver
geschmack was zu heftig oder nicht gut
mit knallte ihm wäre also das war auf
jeden fall geil aber auch heftig zucker
riecht also kann es auch ein
zuckerwürfel essen oder also so hat das
geschmeckt okay gut machen wir weiter
auch schokoriegel in amerika oder kanada
ganz normal so henry sieht es von risi
aok sieht aus wie so ein ereignis dingen
genau wir haben hier den schokoriegel
mit peanut butter so was das doppelte
also das dann kann man sich darauf hin
weil er weniger vor allem wenn das ding
fast so lange sie schon lange
potentielle zeigt dann richtig gut das
ist ein schokoriegel alter markt
befindlichen karten kosten also ist
nichts besonderes also vereinigt also
was heißt war ein essen aber es ist
jetzt nicht so dass ich sage puh hall
innovatives weiß ich noch nie gegessen
habe also man schmeckt bisher diese
airplus butter daraus und sonst merkt
eins zu eins
die haben ja auch das finde ich ein
bisschen lob die haben ja auch wie sie
es einfach zugepackt die gibt es auch in
deutschland oder nicht genau diese hier
ich weiß nicht ob es die genau die leute
kurze kommentar frage gibt es diese
release hier in deutschland
was diese band hey wir sind in die
wohnung gefällt ich glaube da gibt es
nicht hier oder sieht aus wie smarties
schmeckt auch wie smarties mit bisschen
erdnussbutter drin ja gut also ich habe
keinen plan ob sie in deutschland gibt
von der verpackung herzliche da habe ich
schon 20 mal gesehen aber jetzt so bunte
riesig was steht mir meine freundin
fragen die kennt sich da aus zuckerbombe
des todes hier also das ist alles mies
und müssen und christlicher box ist okay
machen wir weiter
hier haben wir zwei sachen gesehen
relativ ähnlich aus und zwar einmal mit
sandwich verstehe warum gut das ist
einmal das ist das gleiche oder oder ist
ein unterschied
ja was ist es denn das weiß ich nicht
das ist mich raus wenn ich es noch mal
vor du hast du hier haben wir mit
sandwich bei den sap entwickelt das wird
auch die pinata die heißen respekt
peanut butter oder kies ach so
das heißt die haben das aber vertauscht
immer meister weil eigentlich sollte
dann noch einmal mit js bach mit peanut
butter glaube ich dass du hast zwei mal
tief in das werde beschrieben als
klassischer cracker mit leckerer käse
befüllt also da muss ich ganz klar sagen
es ist auf jeden fall immer etwas den
ices was auch den leuten zu empfehlen
ist auch dass sie dann 8
hier muss machen sie sieht aus wie ein
kleiner käse käse war ghana
käse käse orion ja stimmen also da bin
ich mal gespannt
schmeckt eins zu eins zu eins zu eins
wirklich dachte ich auffüllen und
probiere ich habe genug
ja gut dass man sich jetzt nicht auf das
ist ja das gleiche wie man sehen kann
ach ja und jetzt sehe ich hier sie haben
noch einen kleinen schokoriegel mit dazu
gepackt filme hier so an den rand
alles klar wie heißt das dingen mister
weg jeder auch der einkaufspreis leider
nicht was kostet so ein schokoriegel
zwei tolle ist eine gute frage
ich würde mal sagen es ist nicht
unbedingt teurer als hier also der
kostet bestimmt im supermarkt 80 cent
oder so weil man muss ja schon sagen die
leute da wo wir in amerika wahl ist es
schon ein bisschen traurig die sind
schon dick zum teil ja aber kann er das
ist ja gut also wir haben hier wieder
einen schokoriegel und lass mich raten
da ist mir schon mit peanuts nein
ausnahmsweise nicht er ist mit einer
vanille waffel und bedeckt von karamell
und reist chips und danach überzogen mit
feinster schokolade und er wird mich
einfach nur umbauen
auf der welt wird das werden wir sehen
[Musik]
das winzig wie eine marke nein für mich
also den computer eingelesen
ich muss immer so lachen wenn ich höre
wenn du sagst deine marke
nein ich muss aber sagen also im
gegenteil der haut mich überhaupt nicht
um ist nicht leisten also es gibt 1000
auf kleinere schokoriegel in deutschland
also das so geregelt angeht hat können
die kanadier wahrscheinlich halt echt
die soviel bruder ist trifft aber nicht
den geschmack oder ist fußballer
geschmacksrichtung das ist natürlich
ganz wichtig aber ich denke mir so was
die sitzenden wir machen man neue
schokoriegel was könnte da der rhein
niemand absolut niemand kanadier und wir
es doch mal mit peanut butter witzig
oder während kommen wir zum gesamten
rems hartes brett gibt es wohl in
deutschland nicht anscheinend kann es
sein ich weiß nicht auch die verpackung
ist halt ganz anders ist es alles mit
lustiger ja so dort direkt außer hier
die gummibärchen und wir hatten bei
dieser japanischen box halt extrem viel
süßkram es hier ist halt alles mit tipps
oder schokoladen und da war halt so
irgendwie so sowie zeigt voll viel also
einmal da ist mit haselnuss mensch merkt
man nicht vor keine ahnung komisch als
ich bin nicht mit der k.box noch gar
nicht zufrieden muss ich sagen ich bin
froh dass ich hier lebe und nicht in
kanada weil die süßigkeiten gefallen bin
ich optimist legalisiert das legalisiert
ab nach kanada damit legalisiert als
letztes haben wir noch so seine anspiele
auf sweethearts meister im text steht
ist ähnlich wie mentors bringen die
geschmacksnerven allerdings noch
deutlich mehr zum kribbeln sieht aus wie
tabletten große ecstasy-tabletten sehen
aus wie drogen muss ich sagen oder wenn
man mal drauf weiß leider nicht wie so
etwas aussieht warten
wir bringen den geschmacksnerv minister
sei schlimmer als die sachen die wir mal
probiert aber auch hart aller ist das
reicht mir auch erst haben wir diesen
süßigkeiten videos genug süßigkeiten für
die nächste woche
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen seid
gespannt auf das nächste unboxing mal
gucken welches land dann dran kommt ich
bin wirklich gespannt weil ich
interessiere mich sehr dafür süßigkeiten
aus der ganzen welt
probieren aber mit den kanal activity
glocke wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr
wieder das hat mir ein schauer